I might win it and I am a get rich quick
at clicker all those things in your
newsfeed on Facebook or Instagram I
think they are amazing I'd love to be
millionaire in 6 months so I believe
them all I click them all I invest all
my own money into it here's every where
I put my money this is what happens over
the next year this is what was promised
these are the results and that's what I
do I put that concept onto YouTube
what's the success ratio being like none
of them worked so far which is because
the only people that seem to get success
from it are the people that are selling
you their calls to do it which is I mean
maybe I'm just unlucky they can work
they just don't so far but I still carry
on in hope I will be a millionaire this
time next year from all of these
different schemes
I am joined by Russell Brunson's best
friend and the undirected king of
LinkedIn Mike win it Mike welcome to the
show
thank you it's a pleasure to have you
here
massive fan of your YouTube channel and
the work that you've been doing recently
lots of talk you've heard today I think
a lot of the listeners will be very
familiar with internet marketing and get
rich quick schemes and they'll be
targeted by the ads probably on this
video on YouTube it will almost
definitely be targeted by those ads so
yeah we've got a lot to delve into today
so for the listeners that don't know who
you are would you be able to explain
what you've been doing on YouTube over
the the last few months
yes so I am Mike Wynn it and I am a
get-rich-quick ad clicker so all those
things that's in your newsfeed on
Facebook or Instagram I think they are
amazing I'd love to be a millionaire in
6 months from drop shipping or through
flipping products on eBay and affiliate
marketing so I believe them all I click
them all I invest all my own money into
it and I report my results as they are
compared to what the claims made by the
Guru's is and that's all I do I put that
content onto YouTube and you can see for
free whether they work or they don't
what's it what's the success ratio being
like none of them work so far the only
people that seem to get success from it
are the people that are selling you
their calls to do it which is I mean
maybe I'm just unlucky but I'll promise
y'all I'm trying my best so far but I
still carry on in hope I will be a
millionaire this time next year from all
of these different schemes I think one
of the you hit straight on one of the
points there which is that unless you
have the money to be able to spend on
these particular courses does you know
there's no way of still proofing them no
no no that's true that's true yes so
there is there is no way it's a
foolproof mother I think but the problem
with them is how they're marketed to
people is if anyone can do this it's
easy
and it's passive income and you can make
this money from two hours a week three
hours a week it's like targeting people
that don't have put the effort in in
many in many ways but also of course
they're gonna make it sound easy and
anyone can do it with no startup cost
because if they said it actually it's
100 hours a week and you need money to
start up and it wouldn't sell it many of
these courses so that's true
yeah it's it's so interesting I think
that proliferation of these sorts of
schemes and and adverts and I mean
anyone who's scrolling down Facebook the
number of times that I've heard the
sentence on YouTube
I can't believe that people are still
working in this old way but like an
Australian guide than an American guide
then a guy from down south and or
whatever guy and it's like what the [ __ ]
is going on yeah yeah yeah it like
stupidly I have worked really hard to
earn money and but I have my own
business I used to do six days a week
16-hour days and I didn't get paid what
they're getting from just doing two
hours in their mom's spare bedroom you
know per week I wasn't getting those
returns and then luckily I was lucky
enough to grow a business and sell a
business and then create enough money to
afford me to do this sort of two-year
little experiment which I regret
sometimes it's like a love-hate kind of
project so be honest yeah well I mean
you've you've recently sort of seen a
massive influx in terms of exposure in
place alright like the last couple of
weeks have been insane what's on 5,000
subscribers two weeks ago and now it's
on 17,000 so last two weeks it's dream
don't trip yeah yeah absolutely
okay the dream but you all know this
more than me because I've never had
Instagram before I've never been on
Facebook before and I'd obviously
started YouTube in January what I find
is the more people that start
subscribing you get two sets of people
you get by fans that love what you're
doing but then also people that hate
what you're doing but they still
subscribe to tell you they hate what
you're doing so it's crazy I've worked
out now it's roughly 1,000 views equals
one thumbs down that's my sort of race
rate at the moment yeah I think that's
about right
it's in
testing as well when you talk about the
little asymmetries in your exposure and
you'll notice this with your better
performing videos and some of the
listeners may know this as well
if you've ever posted a piece of content
which is absolutely banged like gong
gone much bigger like 2x to 10x more
than your usual piece it kind of opens
that sphere of awareness outside of the
usual people that are just a part of
your like crew and they know what you're
about and they're always going to give
you a bit of support and then what you
actually see is like this little use get
to look through the people and you see
the real internet and you're like oh
that's the [ __ ] that's the no-man's
land out there that's the where the
savages live yeah well I've had that
with the Contra pronoun formula video
that's the one that went so my videos
are doing about 20,000 views that was
almost at 200,000 views before he got
pulled and we'll talk about that later
but that did 200,000 views but what that
brought was hundreds and hundreds of
comments like calling me out I mean some
people even noted out a bunch in in the
comments I never know is that before I
had a YouTube video very observant the
people of the internet crazy it was news
to me but it just makes me think
sometimes it's like some of the comments
on there for example this is a channel
for losers but then he's made that
comment on every single video but you
always want to say so what you still
doing here that yeah why have you got so
much time on your hand if I'm the loser
how come you've got so much time on your
hands I know I know it's it's funny
though but that's the biggest thing so
like you're a you're unsuccessful that's
the only reason doesn't work
you're a loser you'll never quit the 9
to 5 grind and all these things ileum
forms comments really but I suppose
that's how people got on your life it's
just the internet isn't it it's that it
brings out the worst in people because
you can hide behind a fake profile fate
username so there's an interesting point
that John Peterson made actually in an
interview a year ago and he said that
because social media is so new he was
specifically referring to Twitter but
the same thing works for every social
media we don't know what causes people
to respond like we haven't done a study
on which people how the date of skews on
which people reply to tweets or
which people comment on YouTube videos
it might be that it's skews massively
towards the people that had a bad day
maybe if you've had a good day you just
don't you don't respond for whatever
reason you're either in too good of a
mood or whatever it is but it might skew
that like 90% of the comments that you
get from people that have had a ruthless
ly bad day
so they might not actually be ourselves
but we just don't know and when you look
at it when you take an aggregate view
across the board just looks like
everyone's a [ __ ] yeah I said there's a
video on YouTube and we talked about
it's in our office it is it's David
Attenborough Attenborough isn't it you
know the animal guy and it's called
they've been Attenborough talks about
giraffes and it's a four-minute video
about giraffes and it's got thirty five
bones down but it's just giraffes and
favorite talked about it and it makes me
think what were you expecting there's
still 35 people that hated that video
enough to say oh no I'm good I'm gonna
thumb that down David I know and even it
was like ah his voice is terrible it's
like David yes we've decided to make a
joke now that we'll have a 40 minute
video that goes up and it'll have one
thumbs down as soon as it gets uploaded
so someone's subscribe specifically to
for my stuff down stops what they're
doing give it a thumbs down post
notifications turned on though they've
listened to you they've turned the post
notifications on they're just another
wrong reason and it's it's just funny
how people are on there and how people
are on LinkedIn towards it now because
obviously the the message has got a bit
more serious now and I think people
thought I was joking when I first
started because I said I'll put my money
where my mouth is and I will invest in
these things to prove over they work or
not because I'm not calling all a scam
per se I'm just saying I think the
results promised are highly unlikely but
let me see if it does work and if it
does work you can copy what I did for
free doctor pay me for the course you
can watch how it works
mm-hmm absolutely before we before we
get into the thick of it ladies and
gentlemen if you are listening right now
heads to wherever you are and give us
five stars or give us a thumbs up let us
know that you're listening and fight
against the our cells of the internet
thank you very much and so the first
thing I wanted to know Mike was actually
the to roll back a little bit and work
out what you did before this because in
one of your videos you mentioned you had
a company and then you managed to get an
exit yeah I think you fondly refer to it
as being kicked out of your own company
with a with a paycheck could you give us
a brief bit of history with that yeah so
I had a company that I set up with three
of my friends it was called learning
heroes and it was we would make blended
learning resources so elearning content
animated explainer videos on loads of
stuff like cybersecurity data protection
leadership team working working at
Heights just normal boring work stuff
but made in a style that was more in
keeping with how we'd learn at homes
that we short animated explainer rather
than click Next death by PowerPoint so
it's basically interest they Neal
earning if there is such a thing there
wasn't really if I'm honest we sold that
to corporates
and then corporates could use that in
that company to help them train their
stuff so we made content for trainers to
use to do employee training basically
and it was always a three year plan so
we thought make the business grow the
business look to partner certain
companies that might want to buy us out
look to target some companies that do
similar things to what we do and they
might want to buy us out to protect
their client base create competitive
tension sell to one of them then walk
away with our money and it was a three
year three year ten million pound plan
and we did it almost we didn't quite get
the ten million we've got eleven million
dollars it was eight million in cash two
and a half years later that sounds out
that sounds like an incredibly well laid
out and well executed plan had you had
success in business like this before
no I had worked in two startups before
so I had seen startups from almost day
one through so maybe two three four
years down the line and I was a trainer
a sales trainer for a company that sold
franchises so every week when a new
franchisee come on I would help them set
their business up so it was like I was
kind of helping
dance at businesses week after week and
I'd stay with them for a couple weeks so
I was doing it for a salary for other
people for ages in a completely
different sector by the way and I just
thought what am i doing building someone
else's business when I've got all the
knowledge I can see what's worked for
them I can see what they could do better
and trying to play it to a sector that I
thought we could grow a business and an
e-learning was the easier sector in my
mind at the time well I opened it no
background in that sector one
unbelievable identification of a niche
to capital it was this wasn't sound like
a crazy story so I just walked out at
the job at the time had a baby on the
way and a good money and had a bit of a
disagreement with the boss and he said
my problem is I want everything to run
perfectly he said if you had your own
business it'd be very small and very
well-run but it wouldn't be much money
so I handed in my notice right there it
was like telling the morning come home
and then he said they basically put my
gardening so I had six weeks to come up
with an idea and then I looked at what
jobs were available basically in every
job description was saying stuff like
must be able to work in a team must be
able to manage your time properly and I
thought you don't have a GCSE in site
management what courses are available
looked online saw the courses and it was
like a four hour course on time
management and it was like click Next
and four well if I want to find anything
out at home like one YouTube watch five
minute video and that's what the idea
came from why don't we learn at work how
we learn at home and then I had friends
that had a training business and they
had they did a lot of face-to-face
training and between ourselves we caught
with the idea that was it it's great
it's honestly the fact that I suppose
this is kind of oddly romantic given the
path that you've gone down at the moment
the fact that it was such a
transactional relationship between you
and your business which ended up being
like the one that banged it was just
find a niche yep I don't furnish crack
on I don't understand like a like a bit
of a weirdo but I've got a kind of
checklist that I think a business would
work in this sector so if the sector
these certain criteria I think and I
comply this checklist to that sector
this will blow if anyone that's watch
this to supply some people's minds if
you read the YouTube comments I've I'm a
failure in business I'm just an internet
troll but yeah it's a but my legit
business
I've got like a checklist that I follow
there's to be certain market conditions
you have to be able to offer a genuine
alternative that was one of the biggest
things in eLearning
if you want me to talk specifically
about e-learning but everybody here's a
great example recruitment agencies
there's hundreds of them and most
recruitment companies started up by
someone that used to work for a
recruitment company right are way
different but the only difference is
they charge one percent less or the fees
are slightly small they haven't got a
genuine USP but the old lights are say
the different what we did with
e-learning was we looked at and
everybody charged per course per head
long contracts
it was long drawn-out content and we
just thought why don't we do the
complete opposite so we'll just is pay a
monthly subscription and when you can
get access to all of our content similar
to Netflix so it's a Netflix will give
you new content every week so when a new
course comes out you gotta pay as anyone
when you can have it for free and we
said if you don't like what we do we
don't wanna keep someone unhappy just
leave we're not asked just just leave
we're not trying to get the most money
out of you we want you to be a fan and
advocate and we did that and we
absolutely just tore like hammered the
industry we were taking people's writing
center and people said you must have
your pricing wrong because it's so much
cheaper than everyone else's and we said
no they've all done it wrong this is how
it should be done and it was one of the
companies that told us in the first few
months that you know we wouldn't be
around if we carried on like that that
ended up showing the most interested
buyers out amazing it was it's quite an
interesting story in many ways but not
to sound weird but we knew it was going
to work we knew it's going to happen so
we sort of planned for that exit in the
first couple of weeks it was like this
is the day we are going to sell and this
is how much we want so every decision we
made on that way was backwards planned
from that point unbelievable that's so
good man it's great it's really nice to
hear especially given that you've work
through the industry and a lot of people
that are listening right this kinda ties
into I suppose why people are tempted to
do these online courses from the Contra
preneur the online marketers because
they want that they want to be able to
know that in three years time I've got
an exit that's worth nearly ten mil like
that's you know that's that's the goal
the [ __ ] golden dream that everybody
wants but yeah the whole point of what
you've come across there is the youths
you had some existing experience which
at least allowed you to frame the
particular situation appropriately and
then moving forward you came up with
unique product and then just single
single mind aim towards the goal that
you knew that you wanted the whole yeah
the whole point of that is the fact that
you had a unique offering that without
the unique offering everything else
would have just fallen apart but the
first thing that strikes me about these
online marketing courses is that if
everyone is learning the same thing as
you you're offering cannot be unique by
definition I say it so many times
logic would state you are turning your
customers into competitors and it's the
shittiest business model ever that's
that's why it doesn't work it's like oh
I'm going to teach you so if I had a
property seminar and I did proxy
training in Warrington and I'm showing
I'm talking to a thousand people and I'm
a property investor and I make most of
my money in property in Warrington and I
can tell you how to find below market
value deals
why would I teach a roomful of a
thousand people how to do the thing that
I earn my money from I want as a few of
you to know how I make my money so I can
carry on making my money unless whisper
it I'm not making that much money from
actually property investing I'm making
money from teaching people how to invest
in property which is something I think
that a lot of these people do it and
yeah gone so let's get into it how would
you define a contra preneur so really I
think entrepreneurs is someone that
sells shovels to a gold rush so they're
telling everybody there's a gold rush on
this is how you can become rich and
wealthy yet they don't make money from
the actual thing that they're telling
yours you to do they are selling you
theory on how to do it but
there's no evidence to suggest that
they've made that money doing that very
thing and that's what it is and it's
targets as many people as possible so
sound as easy as possible and then once
they've got you in their sort of sales
funnel
they will upsell you well you know what
the reason why it's not worked at this
stage six months down the line is
because actually if you just pay me
another three grand from I wants a month
mentor and I'll give you an extra bit of
the secret sauce and then the reason why
it's not work now well the reason why
it's not work is because it doesn't work
but they'll still temperature well
there's actually a higher level to get
to and then you'll know the real secrets
and the real secret so it's just
basically getting you into the net
following you through and take this much
money from you as possible that's it
basically
and you it's they follow pretty much the
same script it doesn't matter what the
passive income fingers that they're
selling the language is the same the
form you learn the process that they use
to get you in the net even through so
the same back stories I hear the same
back story different events now because
I go to all these events and so that's
what they do they basically sell shovels
to one trip Rinna's and people desperate
to leave they're up the rat race
basically yeah the mantra panel
entrepreneurs nice yes so they're
conscious players and they basically
sell the genes of entrepreneurs and
sometimes it's fun little people
desperate people but I'll say this and
be clear I don't think that all
trainings but I don't think that all
trainings are car and I don't think that
anybody single person ends their price
in a seven which is something that a lot
of them do is a conce because if you
read their YouTube comments some people
take what you say literally like oh well
he's got a price it's a seven so you're
saying he's a scum like know if you get
value from that and you have achieved
that thing from that person he isn't a
contra preneur to you he might be to the
99 percent of other people that failed
on his course so I mean once blood don't
everyone see so basically spell it out
to them say right this person's AK
entrepreneur this person is country
right I don't know every single one of
them but people want me to say my DM now
is what about this guy is here contra
knows that I've never heard it again
[ __ ] clue yeah you're not you're not
the glossary you're not Wikipedia fork
entrepreneurs on the internet oh you
think I was though yeah from my tip my
DMS it's crazy
well I think the reason for that is that
so few of the people are doing this
everyone else is drinking the kool-aid
but the only people that you see that
are touting these sort of online
get-rich-quick scheme courses are their
ambassador's or the showcase clientele
that they've got and for the fact that
you are the only person that I've ever
seen really that's not like just some
disgruntled sounding like old like wife
from God knows where the backend of
Nebraska or something like that who's
written a bad review on Trustpilot I
don't I don't know I don't understand
the process and so you weren't you went
and did a lot of these courses right do
you know how many you've done yeah well
I've been through 12 actual events like
face to face well here's my clickfunnels
event here's my affiliate marking event
here's my dropshipping event here's my
brand event but how I actually started I
didn't set out to do this so when I sold
the business and I got given a lump sum
of money I I mean I don't know your
background but we're working class kids
we're not told how to handle money we're
not told how to handle that I'm a 20
that's how come you know when people win
the lottery and they blow 6 million 7
million rounds like ha that would never
happen to me that is a lot easier than
you think because you do not know what
to do you don't understand people think
if you have a million pounds put it in
the bank live off the interest you can't
do that your interest is probably 0.9
percent inflation 3 percent you actually
lose money putting a million pounds in
the bank but people don't understand
this concept and that's not their fault
that's because working-class people
aren't taught this stuff because we're
supposed to be good workers and so I was
given this money I thought I was doing
the right thing and going to find
financial experts and independent
financial advisers to tell me what to do
with my money because I thought I've hit
the jackpot here
I could i bribe the best two years of my
life and then get back home have a job
or be boring and make sure that for
their next 40 years I get paid a steady
income from this money in it alone if
you say 20 30 40 grand a year I say only
that's a lot of money but it's not I'm a
millionaire money it's it just pays your
bills or you know so that was the plan
every single person that's all 15
different financial aid buys
invest in all sorts of stuff and my
question was always the same don't tell
me what returns I will get if you
believe in the asset you're trying to
get me to invest in so much how much
it's your own money have you gotten this
so if you're telling me to invest in a
Cayman Islands because I can make 300%
logic would state every single penny
you get paid you'd put in the Cayman
Islands because then it makes three 300%
back on it not one person not one person
would I ever show me how much they've
invested in their own asset or how much
they were really getting which they made
me think so they make more money from
telling other people to invest in this
you know amazing investment opportunity
or do they actually really believe what
they're selling and then I just thought
you know what I'm gonna look at some
more left field investments like crypto
mining and some of the exact you know
property we all know you can make money
from property long-term 10 years 15
years and stocks and shares over time
you consider but the ones that may made
sort of like we raise my eyebrows or the
interesting ones were there anything
that was flashy
anyone had a 23 year old Lambo I just
put a little pot of money into these
things almost like a gamble you know
I'll put 5 grand into that 10 grand into
that and that's what I've done but to
the tune in every five hundred thousand
is that your total costs or Fowley and
this is why when people say you want
this to fail you could be further from
the truth
you could be further from the truth so
we've got properties we bought in the UK
just to test the returns that were
promised by some of the people that
we've been on the course is property in
Spain
we've got crypto mining rigs they've got
like a crypto farm running to chess
those results we've invested in
cryptocurrency as an asset rather than
mining it we've got we've just just
bought an affiliate marketing site I did
the video last week so we even put
10,000 into an affiliate marketing site
we've got stops in shares
I've put 250 thousand into stocks and
shares and it's just going to be hears
everywhere I put my money this is what
happens over the next year this is what
was promised these are the results
then I would almost give them a result
would I invest with this again knowing
what I know now yes or no
am I gonna make this amount of money I'm
gonna make a billion power no you're
more likely to make 10,000 pounds don't
quit your job if you want to do this and
that's all it is really a but I don't
want anything to fail or not
deliberately trying to sabotage anything
you need you gotta have a very
particular mindset if you want something
to fail to the tune of alpha million
quid yeah you're the first person I've
told that bit to most people don't think
I think they just think that I'm going
there and deliberately you know trying
to just just show up the people that are
on stage but I'm not they're naming
individuals it's more like an
observation of the actual asset or the
passive income stream rather than this
guy who's a con artist because you know
I'm giving them all the benefit they
don't I think they really are just
trying to give back to her to other
people and help them become millionaires
it's not they're not doing it so lie in
their own pockets I think they really
are giving back in their genuine people
yeah so one of the things that I thought
and we'll get onto the Contra preneur in
a second because really now that it's
been taken down the only way that we can
talk about it at the moment is by us
discussing it the only way that people
actually know what the [ __ ] going on
is by this weird retrospective like
nostalgia that we're going to have to go
through but what one of the things that
I thought to be really interesting was
the fact that you a new team elected not
to name names and yes I think there's a
point where you go and you manage to
wangle of meeting with Gary Vee in new
year and you go see him and you sit down
and you're on camera in that famous
office he's got which just looks like
chaos and he's pushing you to say like
who are the people and then rather than
like That's Gary it's Gary [ __ ]
Vaynerchuk like the listeners will know
I've got mixed feelings about Gary but
like what you think about him aside that
is the opportunity if you were ever
gonna do it and not be called out by the
people on the internet it's like look
Gary Vee wanted me to [ __ ] tell him
but what you elected to do was cut the
recording so you cut the recording and
told Gary and then you cut back in so
what I really liked about that was the
fact that it shows that this isn't a
head hunt or at least primarily this
isn't a head hunt from you guys this is
you with Jamie
in sort of inquisitiveness and a little
bit skepticism just trying to find out
what the [ __ ] going on trying to cut
through some of the [ __ ] yeah that's
it like I don't want this to be and I'm
not saying just say it's John Smith I
don't want this to be an expose of John
Smith because in my mind what happens is
this there are 99 other people that are
using exactly the same tactics as John
Smith
but if then you he's he's the Contra
preneur guy it doesn't solve the problem
several things I've not been scammed by
that guy if I just make people aware of
the tactics used in the industry if they
get that feeling ah this sounds a lot
like that contra no formula they will
then start to question whoever's trying
to sell them though to them in that way
in my mind I think that actually helps
more people than just saying oh this is
I don't know I just picked random gurus
like the Tony Robbins show or this is
the what the Gary Vaynerchuk well
whoever it is there might win it you
know might win it's the contraband
whoever is I just think that was better
but also I don't wanna get sued I don't
know yet sued and and what I've noticed
is there's a lot of people that have got
a lot of powerful friends and these
people make a lot of money for a lot of
social media platforms as obviously I'm
finding out now there's only gonna be at
this stage one winner in that let's
expose them now but I tell you what Gary
actually told me that I do need to name
someone he thinks that I should name
someone and if I want to take it's a
Netflix it needs to be named someone but
I think that's based on the name I told
him off camera she says go as Gary got a
an agenda there I mean only he can
answer that honestly I mean I can
speculate I would suggest that when I
told him the name of the person and he
was pretty much balancing off the wall
saying yes you know that would suggest
that he also thinks the same about that
person but you know he's been on the
same card as a as that person he spoke
at the same events grunty they weren't
on stage together but they've been at
the same events so it's he doesn't mind
getting paid to be there well
person's there so you can mrs. me being
balanced and neutral on it I've got very
similar feelings I think so Gary beers
you have but then at the same time if
you're putting out content every day
you're gonna say a lot of things that
contradict each other and safai answer
he's a unique guy Gary so might my only
like so my major gripe I'm gonna go off
in a Gary tangent for like one minute my
major people now think that I'm like
best buds with them yeah yeah like I've
met the guy once and he said he was good
in traduce as a Netflix
he's still not managed to do that yet so
I I'm not a Gary Vee fun I'm not go if
you hate a Gary B is just the guy that
one's a business and could potentially
help me out or not that's it as far as
I'm concerned [ __ ] me like you Garak
Gary's contacts are unbelievable so I'm
good friends with the guys from social
chain which isn't far from you in
Manchester Biggs yeah your agency good
good friend hood Dom who's the CEO oh
and a bunch of the guys that were there
from the start and I discussed this with
about about Gary there and my only major
concern about Gary is that he doesn't
sleep enough that's my major concern I'm
just thinking there's a couple of
immutable truths in life right and like
not sleeping equals earlier death and
Alzheimer's like that's it that is a
fact same as dropping a ball from a
height like it is it's coming for you
Gary because there's some toxins in your
brain that really really need to [ __ ]
off and Oleum Islands this whole work
you know - your eyes bleed that
mentality it's dangerous I get you have
to work hard you can't sustain up for 23
hours a day for three years five years
ten years because all you're doing is
this it's got there's a reaction or a
consequence that is you're shortening
your life by 10 years 15 years 20 years
so yeah some of the advice he gives I
think is it's [ __ ] but then but
you'll notice from the internet I think
on the internet people think if you like
someone you have to agree with
everything they say they say one thing
you disagree with is how I hate up nose
no I don't like a person now so I don't
agree with loads of things my friends
say you don't fall out with them or
oversight they say some things that's
true they say something that's [ __ ]
you just but with the internet is crazy
and it's like people I love Gary
everything he says it's gospel don't say
don't think that stupid if you think
that you don't
and I think sometimes people say
everything he says is gospel and like
you've got to do that you don't I think
a lot this that we says of [ __ ] if
I'm on it mmm yeah you totally right the
overworking thing I've done it and you
may have done it as well in the past
like in your 20s Jordan Peterson again
to sing his praises he says that
everybody in their twenties who's an
entrepreneur it would be a good idea for
them to work out just how much they can
work so they you 20s you don't have
sufficient responsibilities that are
going to hold you back from working to
your maximum capacity and he actually
suggests that for short periods see if
you can do 14-hour days six days a week
and see what happens and I didn't do it
by design but I've done that more by
neuroticism I think but um and fear but
yeah I've done that and I've played
around with that and then he's saying
well okay now see what happens if you
only work two days a week and I've also
tried doing that um the two days a week
for me personally was a lot worse
because of the cabin fever than the 14
hours but I think you're right
Gary you have put the words hustle and
grind on the bottom of Perak a Swiss
like it soon as soon as you've done that
you you kind of you kind of out of the
chill out of from work conversation like
that see you over there with the hustle
and grind shoes on yeah sources
abandoned gary was there and just seeing
people with his trainers on in that and
like seeing brook people grow up like
grown men cueing because you put you're
paid if you wanted like a diamond ticket
so you could sit two rows closer than
the people that paid ten times less that
behind you and you got to ask Gary a
question grown men in case with hostile
and clouds and whatever it is heaven in
Hell's shoes whatever the [ __ ] it
was if they were wearing one question
you can ask Gary B this is the guy that
you you know you worship your idolized
just can I have a hug grown men saying
can I have a hug and I was just like
what's this world come to that you can
ask them anything about business you
could ask him but that's what it came
down to oh it's just a weird kind of
world we live in what a bizarre
situation so getting back to the Contra
preneur can you take us through the
Contra preneur formula please yes so the
Contra formula was after going to
numerous events and live events
like say the 10x the success resources
and property shows and anything any of
these like type events that you see all
the time advertised what I started to
notice is almost verbatim was the same
script used by every single speaker it
turns out by the way I can't remember
the guys name now there's a trainer that
trains these people on you know that
scripts which I may or may not be signed
up to go to so to the point where so Ian
is my business partner he was also in
the old business as well it's like a we
slowly getting even shot a few times he
just like he's like is he the big
beautiful don't don't say that he's been
a day is we look very similar thing yeah
you do yeah it watches as well yeah
sorry you look great there you go yeah
so yeah so to the point where me and Ian
could almost look at each other and say
the next bit they'll talk about a
[ __ ] backstory and say ah here's the
time where they they were the one that
you know went out on a limb and they got
this amazing opportunity three two one
hey and then my daughter twisted her
uncle and then the coach came over and
it was like what that player twisted her
ankle in the coaching room said is
anybody bought the boots yes my daughter
was there good to go and she got the
game and and literally I could I can
word for word exactly what they say and
we're like this is absolutely [ __ ]
so we just thought why don't we write
this scripts from these shows and
actually test what these people say so
when these were saying stuff like this
is a once in a lifetime opportunity I'm
never gonna offer this price again we
thought that's really interesting we'll
just go to your next show that you're
doing in two weeks time at a different
place and we'll just check fact check
everything that you say and we found out
that they were lying inks it's exactly
the same pitch with exactly the same
price and the show that they said they
weren't going to do ever again they were
doing it three weeks time at a different
venue to the point where we started
seeing the same plants in the crowd at
different events so they are paid for
professional customers that get dead
excited rush off first because some of
them are working on reception sign in as
in registered registration at some event
but then they were in the crowd running
onto stage let me sign up now so we just
started - no it's like a lot of strange
things happening and we just thought
this is quite funny why don't we turn
this into a program were an episode on
and put on YouTube and we call it the
contra player formula exposed and then
that's what we did so we explained about
the use of a sort of [ __ ] backstory
there's always a warm-up act they get
you to commit so they get it to commit
and all these events starts off with
they make you raise your hands and it's
very much like hypnosis so it'll be so
who here wants more money everybody's
hand goes up who here would like more
time who here thinks they deserve more
everybody's Haddon goes up if someone
didn't put their hand up they would be
singled out and it was like a shame in
practice so they would say oh you sir
mister I've got I've got enough money
you don't need enough money and then
from that point on he would always but
it was it's part of the show it's part
of the whole [ __ ] if I don't put my
hand up I'm gonna be shamed no one likes
to be shamed in front of a a big crowd
so there was shaming then there was the
[ __ ] [ __ ] back story of I was
sucked just where you were two years ago
I was working 60 hour weeks for a boss
that doesn't appreciate me and I had
mortgage payments and you know you can
think about this for a year and you're
still gonna be in the same position but
you need to take this opportunity now
grasp it it's all is it shall TV
childhood you know the influence yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it follows that
process and then well I took the
opportunity and you know what what would
you lose if you don't do this and then
it would be that amazing opportunity
presents itself I took the first step
you could take the first step today and
then it comes down to testimonials so
here are people that were just like you
from last year on the other stage which
turns out now obviously been to a lot of
these events some of these are
professional testimonials they go to all
these events and read out the same
script so I've seen the same two or
three people at different events saying
yes I signed up to this course so
different people different different
events for different speakers yeah yeah
yeah Wow Wow okay so this is even like
these mini mini industries for people
facilitating these people
yeah of course yes but I'm not I've not
gone let's go and expose this I've just
been going there to say let's go and
find some stuff to invest in wow that's
the same girl that was in Birmingham
three weeks ago that run on stage what
is she doing running on stage at this of
him oh [ __ ] that's the same person that
rushed the back room to sign up at the
course that event ah hang about why she
signings in today when she was the
testimonial three weeks ago this seems a
bit weird and it's almost almost it was
amusing to us it was just funny to us
right well this is so it's so [ __ ]
it's unreal so that was all that's all
it wasn't any PM scarcity so oh by the
way you know no increase that value so
normally my products 30,000 pound oh
sorry twenty-nine thousand nine hundred
ninety seven because it's always a weird
price but today because you guys have
took the first there you know I'm gonna
sell this price for three hundred and
ninety seven pound it's like you're not
going to give someone like 98 percent
off if it was really run you won't be
selling it for 99 percent off which is
it's like it's never been that price
just so it's the same inflated value and
then often it was so then everyone's
dead excited and then the first three or
four people get to you know sign up and
by the way we've only got ten of these
left today
they say there's ten left so it's fake
scarcity I've got no problem with these
tactics when they're real real
testimonials are cool you know I am a
genuine advocate of that product it's
helped me that product was really thirty
thousand pounds and it's a genuine
discount you know fifteen thousand all
in things are cool and they are real
sales tactics that work it's the intent
of the person using them and whether
it's fake
or off then I think that's what I've got
a problem with you know if you're a good
person trying to give someone a good
product that is valuable and will help
them achieve their goals these tactics
are perfectly fine in my appeal
but fake testimonials fake scarcity
people pretending to be customers in the
audience rush into the back room that's
not cool in my mind
so yeah they rush to the back of the
room they'd say there was only ten of
these products left they'd still take
money from 70 people with no due
diligence it wasn't like what can you
afford to do this and
in a position to pay this 2,000 pound
now people depend on credit cards I've
seen young glad signing up to property
courses aged 16 17 they can't get a
mortgage at that age so why are you
allowing them to sign up to your
property course now I get that some
people watching will say well it's their
own fault for signing up yes I get that
but at 16 17 year old lads in that
scenario that's not world wise and just
been solved the dream that he can be
financially free and not have to work
again and they even say stuff sorry we
took off on a tangent they even say
stuff like your friends and family won't
understand this if you talk to them
they'll tell you that it's not worth
doing it's almost like isolating you
from sort of logic well they're losers
they've never achieved it they bought
the pill that you go they've swallowed
the [ __ ] that you go into college
and you work a nine to five and it's 40
hours a week and you struggle all your
life to pay off your mortgage it's very
clever what they do anyway so then they
sell you that with the fake scarcity Lee
sign you up and then before you know you
in the sales funnel and then they are
offering you upsell upsell ups on that
every single stage the point where they
offer you the chance to come and talk at
their event at a testimonial as part of
their premium package and I know people
that are on stage in Florida talking and
events to convince other people that
their business has been transformed
since they've signed up but I know these
people I know their business because
there are friends of mine and they're
not making any more money now than they
were six months ago when they sign up to
this course they've just spent an awful
lot of money to have a few pictures with
celebrities hang around with these
business mentors and now convince other
people that these scams work does that
make sense
it's incredibly predatory that's the
first thing that comes to mind
especially when you're talking about
young people vulnerable people but
obviously if you were in a stable happy
life with a job that you loved you
wouldn't be like going to see Robert
[ __ ] Kiyosaki at the sage in
Gateshead or something like that you
wouldn't be doing that so first off
they're already selecting for the people
who want this to be the answer to their
problems which in suggests that those
people have problems then they're using
tactics which are purposefully
manipulative neuro-linguistic
programming the stuff from rock bob
shell Dini F up Rory Sutherland on who's
a friend of Bob's and he was talking
about how powerful that stuff is I've
also had Robert Greene the guy that
wrote for yet lost power and mastery and
laws of human nature and stuff like that
I don't know whether you know this but
the reason that Robert Greene made 48
laws of power the way that he did he
says that it is a cookbook with
ingredients but not a recipe and the
reason that he did that was so that bad
actors couldn't use the tools in a mini
relative fashion and the fact that
[ __ ] Robert Greene five times over
New York Times bestselling author is
having to like nerf his own product to
stop bad actors like these ones getting
ahold of his tactics and using them to
their manipulate people and then on top
of that's like finish off the whole I
mean I'm a club promoter right that's my
business I run nightclubs I have done
for 13 years and we use some scarcity
will hold the queue 20% longer than we
need to we'll slow the entry because if
you walk in past a club it's got a big
old queue outside you're like [ __ ] you
know there we go a bit of social
activity a little bit of you know
associated high esteem for going to that
venue but there's a big difference
between slowing a queue down by like 20%
and paying people to sprint to the back
of the venue to spend five grand on a
thing when you're surrounded by
vulnerable people who've just been told
by now if you buy now then you can buy
now and you need to buy now like if you
keep on repeating these things and using
these tactics it's incredibly
manipulative and obviously the worst
thing is it's [ __ ] effective yeah
woman the Buy Now thing so the script
that we recorded we were a branded
events event where a guy said boost your
business it was a crazy claim he could
change any business from his business
plan he was going to give you four three
nine seven three hundred three hundred
ninety seven pound which is usually five
thousand dollars but five thousand
pounds 397 it is basically a GSE
business based black plan you
the line is [ __ ] anyway he would
turn your business into it
ten million pound business in eight
months which is a mud claim when you
don't know the sector of the people that
are in your audience or what they're
like as individuals but people swallowed
it seventy people got up and signed up
now in the close of his pitch he said by
now twenty three times in the three
minutes leading up to the price reveal
and it was ridiculous it was like by now
you realize you can't miss an
opportunity like this if you follow this
step by step by now it was like
everything was like it was like bye-bye
bye-bye to the point where like we're
laughing we find it funny interestingly
as well in the crowd when some people
it's like hypnosis and they kind of weed
out the people it won't work on so they
get rid of people that are negative from
the crowd they get told not to come back
or they get they get moves constantly
there's people in the audience being
moved and did it really refuse because
especially being British and being as
disagreeable as I am if someone came
over and I was sat down in a seat and
they said you didn't put your hand up
when you said do you want more money or
more time or something like that I
wouldn't move well asked so into it that
they're already getting shifted around
or yeah it's is it's strange it's like
if you ever watched this or some weird
are you still living a B therfore a long
time ago I used to live in Ibiza and
they used to be a team of pickpockets
that worked on the street below the
apartment so you slip up and I used to
watch them every night and I used to to
the point where I could see the signals
so like woman the flash is lighter than
the the crowd would start moving it was
all basically easy and this this the
street would stand still until someone
came either drunk or intoxicated the
sign would be given to let people know
whether it was under the influence of
drugs or drink and then literally a ball
would roll out into the into the street
a woman would walk past bump him and I'd
see I'd see people get people getting
over and over again the scenes in these
rooms are very similar to that it's like
people move exactly the same times when
I've seen the same show at different
events people it is it sounds like I'm
crazy
explaining it but when you've seen that
many people
at these events and you've seen so many
of these events you'll realize the whole
psychology of the event and everything
is set up for you to spend your money
basically and anybody that doesn't look
like they are going to do that they get
rid of them so the main thing that I'm
struck by there apart from the fact it's
manipulative inand and is taking
advantage of vulnerable people
it's how [ __ ] sophisticated it is
yeah it was big business though isn't it
so
salines events I don't know say it's a
success resources event however much
that person on stage sells they have to
pay fifty percent to success resources
that's how it works so it's big business
so that's why they want to fill the
rooms that's why they get people to move
forward so it looks busier that's why
everybody in that room wants you to
spend money so no one's there trying to
help you if it's not right for you
they're not gonna say you know what and
I think that's why people leave of their
own accord because they realize it's
[ __ ] but everybody else around them
like woo pins that stood up I remember
speaking to one woman no she didn't have
a business and she went and spent 2,000
pound what was 1997 197 on a course to
brand her business and I actually said
to it what are you doing
insured oh no I caught up this is it
this is what I need to book you've not
got a business or service or product
that you sell so what are they gonna
brand oh it doesn't matter they'll help
me come up with an idea for a business
and I just think there's people like
that though she was paid on a credit
card she's not got a business she's not
got a service why are they taking the
2,000 pound off her to help her brand
her business that doesn't even exist yet
it's it kind of blew my mind really but
yeah a lot of people get up and leave
they don't let you eat or drink in there
because then you get a it's called
decision fatigue
yeah so they make you they make you save
like four or five hours before you get
your first break but then after that
break the numbers have dwindled
massively because most people realize
this is a pitch fest I'm not coming back
so anybody that returns after that break
they're more likely to buy and now a
higher product so what happens is so I
call it a tripwire solo by your opponent
to start with who takes the bait right
if 70 people have signed up now we could
probably sell them the vibrant product
in the afternoon and
and the following day it could be well
now we'll get the men sorry but the
following day some people think [ __ ] I
spent 5 grand there I would regret it
they've got you know buyer's remorse so
the next day the number is a lot less
but the number is a lot less but they
are the most qualified people and they
have bought into your [ __ ] the most
and they're buying 20 30 grand
mentorship the warmest leads that you're
ever gonna have in your life oh yeah
yeah yeah of course I don't get me wrong
if this product really did work I'd be
all for it I would be saying you know
but look at the stats the stats show
that maybe 1% of these people what 1% of
people are successful through these
causes it's weird the only people I've
met that are successful through these
are actually part of that organization
or selling you that product so I've not
met someone that's made a million
dollars through the 10x course let's
just say through Graham cardones
university or Cardone capital I'm just a
random example by though I'm not saying
it's here yet I can show you 10 15 20 10
X affiliate resellers that will be
telling me that Grant Cardone has
changed their life and they are
millionaires he's selling his product
you've not made your money through the
thing that he says that we are gonna
make our money from you are making your
money through selling the thing that he
says we are going to make our money from
that I'm yet to meet anyone 100%
unbiased and independent that's gone
actually you know I I invested Cardone
capsule I'm a marine Anna not one person
I mean if you are out there get in touch
yep link is in the show notes below keep
an email us so moving on this really
cool very interesting documentary blows
up on YouTube
I enjoyed it thankfully and then what
happened so I only found out on Saturday
so Saturday
Ian sent me a message saying there's
been a copyright strike or there's a
strike against our channel and Russell
Brunson from clickfunnels who provides
the software that many of these contra
printers use to obviously if you click
on their advert and upset you their
content put a copyright claim in and the
video has now disappeared and it has
been pulled so we are putting a
counterclaim all because we use the 1
second clip of the
Russell Brunson coming out at the 10x
conference and that's what he said was a
copyright infringement we don't think it
will stand well it was not what's this
specific scene sorry so at the beginning
is the sort of an intro to it was just
showing like different events where
people get excited people rush into the
back room people putting their hands up
so it was all like clips taken from all
these different types of events that
we've been going to and there and
there's a the back of Russell Brunson
walking onto stage and then puts his
arms out in front of the crowds you know
it's like a proper moment like Here I am
yes it was a one-second clip of him
there and he's put in a copyright claim
to get the video removes residents put a
copyright claim in against the back of
his own head yeah yeah to be honest you
wouldn't be able to that was also
Blanton but now you can because he's put
a copyright claim in Russell Brunson
knows the back of his own head very well
yeah yeah maybe ice mirrors in his house
well spends a lot of time at a
hairdressers perhaps now all he's gonna
make me do is I will cut that image from
the re-upload and I will name him saying
insert back of Russell Bronson's head
here where that where that would have
been and then put the video out again so
it's not copyright infringement now and
now you will be the only person named in
that video because no one else was named
no one was named in that video before it
didn't point anything to anyone in
person in particular so for you to
actually make it about you you've poked
your head above the parapet Russell and
now clickfunnels is is in the crosshairs
well you know there's been videos made
about it being pulled which I didn't
know there's a guy called meet Kevin I
don't even know him on YouTube he's got
like about 150,000 subscribers and he
did a big video about it and he did a
big video about clickfunnels and him
being friends with Grant Cardone and
saying it's a bad look like why have you
even
basically said I really want 17,000
subscribers not many people had seen
this video but now because you pulled it
down and it's all over the internet
saying video no longer available but it
actually says who's made the copyright
claim yes and now it by I mean I don't
know how this works I don't know
anything about YouTube really but
so now in a lot of people's minds the
contrapunto formula is about russell
brunson but weirdly he was named in the
comment so many times saying oh this is
like the book that was a bronson scott
on telling you how to sell to people so
maybe he's thought you know what this is
basically the contents of my book that i
sell man it's in a book away for free
probably read yeah what we gone to a lot
of his students course it's and just
notice that they are saying the same
thing over and over again and so yeah so
the video is no longer available will
upload it really upload it next week
probably with references to russell
brunson clickfunnels throughout now this
is it we're gonna see like the Contra
pronoun formula like 2.0 director's cut
so thing so there's a few little things
I wanted to change anyway the mud thing
about it was we didn't do that I think
and a lot of people would watch it we
did it but like you said for like a
small group of people that followed us
on LinkedIn which is our main platform
then it got picked up by a cup of
Instagram accounts that shared it and it
just blew up overnight it went from
22,000 views to like 100,000 views in
about two days and then it carried on
growing and it's like nearly 200,000
views but yet the actual Netflix
documentary had all that Gary's books
was about wasn't that so we were gonna
reveal what we've invested in our
results that was gonna be a bigger piece
of work the consequent of Boorman was
just a very specific part of this is the
language that you use at live shows it
wasn't like our year is a contra no
because there's been stuff like I got an
Amazon best seller with a blank book
just to prove how easy it was and how
that can be manipulated so as part of
the Contra form is established Authority
nothing screams authority like an Amazon
bestseller so I thought why don't I just
prove it's [ __ ] write a book that
just says blank page on 144 blank pages
publish it and get it to number one in
Amazon which I managed to do in 24 hours
and then I made an episode about that so
there's loads of things that will be in
the main documentary but that weren't in
the continental form in the book well we
all load that formula and you can watch
it probably next week Thursday Friday or
this week sorry Thursday right amazing
well we'll I'll make sure that the link
to that is in the show notes below if if
it is up what's interesting especially
the the Brunson thing the fact that he's
he's decided to get stuck in I don't
know how much I mean I guess he lived in
a little bit of research whether you
knew who he was before that but his
particular platform clickfunnels
is the basis for a huge number of
internet marketing businesses yeah so
many online businesses use it I don't
get it really it's a bit stupid in my
mind for him to have done that which
makes me wonder was it somebody else in
his office that's done it I'm a little
amazed yeah I've seen it seen their ass
reported it and now we'll probably get
in trouble for the amount of coverage
clickfunnels might get from this a lot
it's a night you know whoever watch it's
going to watch it but it was never about
clickfunnels
now I've got a bit of a beam upon it
about clicking on them do you see what I
mean well you still haven't crossed that
threshold of opening people up to the
masses or naming naming and shaming
someone Russell Russell or Russell's
company or whoever the admin person was
that decided to do or the favor for a
friend
they've named and shamed themselves yeah
yeah it's crazy really but no no maybe
they just thought a quick strike now who
knows I might get two three strikes next
week it's like maybe it's an idea that
you know our reporting about someone
else reporting someone else I don't know
- could the channel so all I do is I
just I just chop I'll just chop anybody
out there any Content now I've used
chocolate industry upload it without it
and just just screenshot their names and
say this is that contra preneur that's
that contra that's that contra preneur
and just do it as if it's subtitles
you know like forum on TV yeah out of
hearing mr. 10x walks on stage Wow yes a
bit interesting really but but it's the
first time to be honest the YouTube
thing's been affecting me a little bit
in a weird way it's cool that a lot of
people watching it but now I'm get I'm
getting hundreds of emails and I'm
getting hundreds of messages and I
didn't want I don't want to sound like
I'm not grateful but I didn't want this
I didn't want to be the Ann Widdecombe
or the watchdog of online entrepreneurs
that was never my intention so as much
as it's nice that people tell me who I
should be investigating why I should be
investigating and telling me all about
how they've been scams I've not got the
time to take individual people's case
and say right I'm going to try and get
you about your six grand that you spent
with this Contra proneural but I think
people think I can or that's what I want
to do it does that make sense it sounds
like I'm great no no no I totally
understand it's like people had seen you
as like Dog the Bounty Hunter
like Mike Mike the entrepreneur hunter
yeah like it's Citizens Advice bureaux
and stuff and that's that's becoming
quite difficult to manage it's almost
like because weirdly as well so Onalaska
will say something complimentary about
watching it or someone actually
investigating and if I don't respond
within 20 minutes then all of a sudden
it's like give me those of abuse and
it's like come on now it's obvious that
people's emotion I mean people's
emotions are quite heated here aren't
they because potentially if they have
had their fingers burned
they're then looking for you as this
potential Savior and then when you don't
appear to be that Savior they're then
redirecting that those feelings that
they've got towards whoever it might be
contra preneur X and they redirect them
towards you yeah it's one so at an
interview with someone that a lot of
people said was a contra preneur now I
have never been to this guy's live
events or live shows so I interviewed
him and let him talk let him talk later
now my own gut feeling was he's not
being truthful with just his body
language the way he wouldn't answer
questions the way politicians hypothesis
he wouldn't answer a direct question
with a direct answer so that would
suggest he was anyway in the comments
people were saying you should have
brought this up about him you should
have bought this so this happens at his
event it probably does but I have not
seen those things happen and you're
talking about things that happen to you
personally that I don't know do you see
what I mean oh you should have if I push
this guy too hard in the first two
minutes of an ins be called him out
you're a liar you do this you do that he
did got up and walked out they wouldn't
put any video for you to watch on
YouTube it would have been him sat down
on me say oh this is the guy here I
think you're a contra preneur I've
tricked you you've come down here I'm
gonna call you out as a contra know you
do lie to people you do rip people you
get someone walks out two-minute YouTube
video everyone's gonna go oh you didn't
answer a single question so it's like
it's weird isn't it so I'm kind of
getting [ __ ] from the people that
support what we're doing and then the
people that don't like what we're doing
as well hmm
yeah on both sides yes it's a much it's
a I don't when really I'm not trying to
expose people I am letting you see how
successful or unsuccessful my personal
investments are in these different
passive income streams not Tai Lopez is
an idiot I'm gonna apply to his house
and punch him in the face which is what
some people want me today yeah
no I'll sign up to Tai Lopez's course I
will do its affiliate marketing course
Tai Lopez says I'm making a million
pounds a year I make five hundred pounds
a year I will say Tai Lopez's course is
[ __ ] that's it
I'm not going to get Tai Lopez in a
headlock and you know who you are you
are from Warrington mate so you might be
quite I don't know I don't know well I'm
a posh gender warrants in now oh okay oh
you've moved it you've moved up in the
world now you'd have to fence him or
something like that wouldn't you'd have
to offer him out in a jewel ian's from
the top part warrants and sending him
Sunday oh yeah it'll do Tai Lopez over
but yeah I think you know to the people
that are listening and I'm gonna guess
considering this is probably one of the
first times I've seen you on another
podcast featuring on something else
Wow so you know there will be a lot of
people listening who have seen you
through that video and I think it's
really cool that you've you've had the
opportunity to kind of speak with this
big bird's eye perspective over exactly
what it is that's happening right
exactly what what's been going on and
what you're trying to achieve with this
stuff and yeah I wonder I wonder how
much of the heightened emotions are due
to the fact that people want to believe
so some people want to believe in what
they're being told by these Contra
preneur and you being someone that calls
it out as untrue is potentially killing
the dream so that's something that
they're unhappy about yeah then there's
the other people on the other side of it
who
leave you so much or believe in the boat
that there is [ __ ] so much that they
see you as like this harbinger of truth
that's gonna fly in and like pull out a
ak-47 and just start like sniping people
there's those people as well but what
both of those people are incredibly like
enraged and and energetic about what
you're doing and I think I think that
leads to like you say these flurries of
emails that I'm sure that you'll have
been getting and stuff like that and it
is it's bizarre as well because
obviously if you'd said when you first
did the Contra pronoun formula like make
you know what's gonna happen in six
months time this is gonna have nearly
quarter of a million views you'd have
been like [ __ ] hell that's great but
on the other side of that you go I
didn't realize all the side effects that
we're gonna come with this yeah yeah is
it's it's so much and then some people I
you're just the same as then that's one
of the biggest accusation to get also
you're you're doing the same you're AK
entrepreneur you're doing the same scum
as them and I ask the same question
every time what am i selling you well
you've got adverts on your YouTube
channel how much are you paying to watch
my content the only adverts I get on my
content are the adverts bike
entrepreneurs because they use the same
tags I tag my stuff with now I am
building a crowd of people that don't
like that [ __ ] you know you get paid on
people clicking the ads and buying the
products I have literally got the worst
type of ads on life my affiliate
marketing course skip ad affiliate
marketing courses are [ __ ] isn't
gonna buy that marking course and people
cut it yeah you must be making loads of
money on YouTube no do you know what so
quarter million sort of two hundred
thousand views on that contra know for
volunteer I think was about it was on
something it's $600
you know in terms about revenue and
they're not going to pay at me now
because it's been pulled some $600 but
that video to make we've been to four
different events we stayed in hotels we
bought diamond tickets to sit at the
front it probably cost us six seven
thousand pounds to make that video my
I'm not making money from this what I
make my money from is my investments
wherever they make money that's it but
some people seem to be oh yeah you are
gonna make money for this or what course
am I gonna release how to spot a contra
preneur course and I'll sell it for
three nine seven eight hilarious if you
did if this was a real long game for
Mike win it to release how to spot a
contra preneur course someone said I'll
yeah I'm finally it was all to get an
Amazon best seller I said I sold 49 49
copies of a 99 p book only mine to pay
seventy percent royalty to Amazon I made
30 people 30 PA become 49 box that I've
not wasted two years and five hundred
thousand pounds like but people just
don't either nah I think they want there
to be some sort of big reveal to be like
I told you so this was the big thing but
it literally isn't all I'm doing is
doing what I wish was available two
years ago I wish there was a channel I
could go to when I had some money to
invest that would give me a hundred
percent unbiased advice or results of
these different investment options
that's it
I'm just making the thing that I wish
was there like when I did the learning
business
I made a learning I wish was available
to me when I was doing eLearning that's
it it's no hidden agenda no big reveal
no uh-huh I've just built a huge crowd
you know you can come to see me talk
with five thousand none of it is it a
weight away right now which there was
because I could make a lot of money
being stood on stage telling people how
to make money from making online courses
so I became it because I became a
millionaire from doing that I probably
got more right to be on stage telling
you how to become a millionaire from
online courses because I've genuinely
done that thing but I don't think it's
right because the reality is you could
come to my office Chris and I could tell
you exactly what I did
day by day for two years and you could
do exactly what I did but the the market
is different now
conditions are different now there's so
many variables that stop that big
million pound exit five million pound
exit 10 min panic see that you can't
dress it up in a course and tell people
if they follow us that by step plan they
will get those results that's the truth
but that's why I'm not on stage telling
people how to become a millionaire
through online courses because we were
we've worked hard we did all the right
things but ultimately it comes down to a
huge element of luck there's somebody
else who values your business on that
set day that you want to sell for what
you want and that can't be replicated
through any course that you do or any
mentorship that's the truth and sure
people don't like me saying that 99% if
you won't won't achieve that thing that
we achieved that's not me being a dick
and yes you can say well you did it so I
can do it yes that's true but I didn't
do it by going to an online course or
signing up to a guru or doing a
mentorship I did it from working really
really hard didn't not pay myself for a
few years
employing people paying stuff before I
pay myself sacrificing holidays doing
all this stuff picking an industry where
there wasn't the competition not picking
something that everyone seems to be
doing a constant forgetting richest like
finding a niche marketing it having a
genuine USP working really really hard
taking massive risk and being lucky
enough to find someone that at that time
was acquiring businesses in that sector
so they could then sell their business a
year later because the company that
bought my business solved the business
problems later must do you know what
they got this will be a sick now so they
bought us they bought 13 other
businesses similar similar sort of yeah
it was all like a online training online
learning they become like one of the
world's biggest learning platforms they
sold for 2.8 billion dollars so if you
work out what our business made up of
that I probably would have been around
about 2020 between 20 22 million but
they did that name once after they
bought us so in some regards cool for
lads from Warrington managed to make a
billion quid and rewards away with two
million quid each the flip side is we
were the [ __ ] that left that much
money on the table and if we just worked
hard for another 10 points we could have
made double triple that money whoa it's
mad innit so sometimes I try not to
think about that too much but in one
regard you say oh wow it's amazing what
you did but you know another way
we might not have souls there's
different ways to look at and the way we
might not have solved so we would never
have known it would have been worth that
much but someone could see more value in
it than what we put on the business
that's ultimately what you're looking
for because someone's only under spent 8
million 10 million 2000 on your business
if they think that it's worth 15 20 25
me yeah a business is only worth what
someone who prepared to pay for it it's
the same as a house isn't it it's like
people say on my house is worth 1
million quid well you put your house up
for one when they create if no one buys
it for six years it's not worth a
million quid but if you keep getting
offers for 750 thousand your house is
worth so yeah so it kind of in in
summary of that one of the things that I
think is really interesting is what you
just said there about the fact that
everybody is presuming that you are
doing this with an ulterior motive
you're doing this to to then flip your
audience that you you're gonna grow and
then be like actually this is the how to
avoid a contra preneur course for 397 or
whatever it might be and the fact that
so many people see that as the immutable
dynamic of online content production it
should be confirmation to anybody if
they need it that this is how pervasive
the issue is like if it wasn't fact that
people can't presume in any world let a
lot of people say to me this podcast
been going for a year and we're about to
probably hit just about a million
downloads soon and the number of times
that people are so like what you know
what how much money you making off it or
when what's the plan next like when
you're gonna start to I'm like if you
could imagine how much time I've spent
I've never been paid so little even when
I was a glass collector in middlesboro
17 years old per hour I've never been
paid so little for doing anything in the
history of my life like I'm not doing
this this podcast doesn't exist for that
reason and the same thing for you guys
starting the YouTube channel it's an
interesting project but the hilarious
thing is and this is what I think a lot
of people should hopefully try and take
on board the things that you do without
an ulterior motive and purely for the
fact that [ __ ] that looks interesting
I'm gonna have a crack at that and then
you know you guys you guys come across
while on camera so you and you had
experience with producing things so you
had some associated skills already in
the
in the wheelhouse so to speak the first
time I'd ever been on cameras January 11
on oh yeah we'd never picked up a camera
before we are literally learning on the
job we have like a clue what we are
doing I tell you what man you come
across incredibly well ya know honestly
if you saw what I was like I get angry
in because they basically gives me a
script that goes right you're saying
this and I said it's easy for you Ian
you just can write the word and then get
called punch in you've got a square edge
you look like it it's alright I saw I
might and then so we've got like little
jokes in the obvious where they want me
to act now I said I'm not an actor no
you need to react to some of these
videos I'm like ah so I'm like pulling
face like oh wow and all that [ __ ] but
yeah I absolutely hate it so the only
thing we experienced one was like
scripting stuff and storyboard stuff
because we used to write content so we
know roughly that will work well timing
work well that might be funny in our
opinion you might think the stuff isn't
funny but that's quite funny but yeah
but in terms of filming editing all that
stuff we are literally learning on the
job you do know you're doing a good job
of it but yeah so the fact that you guys
have a but you know even no skills you
have no skills that are in there but at
least an interest in doing it and what's
hilarious is that downstream from that
you guys are actually growing at a rate
that most YouTube channels would be
would be [ __ ] dream of you know like
the the uplift that you guys have had
recently is the sort of thing that
full-time youtubers that are maybe even
putting loads of money into and and you
know really trying all the different
tricks of the trade but the point is and
this is what's interesting about the
Contra preneur formula and the typical
things that they're trying to put across
is none of those things emerge from
passion all of those things are simply
oh you just need to do this sixty seven
step process or whatever the [ __ ] it
might be and bizarrely all of the best
things that I've done have been when
I've worked fairly hard or something
that I'm interested in ground my nose
against a grindstone for sufficiently
long and then some all rights appeared
on the other end yeah
what's interesting about days and this
is what people so I have what's happened
in arguments on online which I don't
recommend doing by the way to actually
answering some of this [ __ ]
you're doing this for the money as I
know I know point I said I am NOT trying
to make money I am trying to make money
on every single investment I make that
is where I'm trying I'm trying to make
money oh yeah you put 70 thousand used
to subscribers you must be making money
said you don't get paid per subscriber I
could wake up tomorrow at 7 billion
subscribers they don't send me a check
for a million quid it doesn't mean
anything you try explaining that to
someone that doesn't quite know what the
run apart but they'll beat you with that
stick hmm so what you said there I think
by doing this and letting people see how
well or badly I do or some of the
unethical or not very pleasant elements
in these in this industry and in these
specific different passive income
streams I think there will be enough and
this is my ultimate goal there'll be
enough good guys that are genuinely nice
people in those sectors to also have a
problem with the flashy Lumbo forex
traders and the [ __ ] property
trainers and they would love to come to
me and say Mike I don't want you to talk
bad of our industry as a whole because
you can make a living through property
investment or affiliate marketing or
even forex trading whatever it might be
I don't know I would like to work with
you and show you the right way of doing
this ethically and I will then invest my
money with the good guys and they will
make that work for me that is ultimately
why I think does that make sense it's
like natural selection or like natural
evolution I suppose for people because
for any online entrepreneur potential
contra preneur for any of those guys to
come to you like you recently had the
the gentleman from Birmingham utas
property had him on and if someone wants
to step into your podcast studio what is
it not another [ __ ] with the podcast
is that it take over the podcast podcast
that was a joke because basically
everyone's got a podcast something they
drove me included and if someone wants
to step into that arena with yourself
with the platform that you guys have now
and the exposure that you guys have now
and the
track record that you guys have now they
better [ __ ] hope that they're
bringing something legit because if
they're not bringing somebody legit they
are going to get found out and you know
so we can put it out as a lovely way to
finish off this podcast we should been
absolutely fantastic if you are an
online market or an entrepreneur who
thinks that you can make genuinely make
people money and you coming seekers out
work with us and we will document that
journey and if it works it works it is
the best advert for you and your
services ever is that but you know what
not one person's gone here you can come
and film our opinion not one which I
think speaks volumes
jomi well that's a nine the affiliate
marketing guy that it's quite in touch
he got in touch to say I know you're
doing so far on affiliate marketing I'm
not a millionaire
I'm not promising to make you a
millionaire however here is my projected
income this is how much I earn and I'm
happy to show you how I do it because I
there are some good guys in this sector
I don't sell a course I don't solve
mental and [ __ ] I just do this for
myself and I'd be happy to work with you
guys to show you the right way of doing
things and that's great and he seems a
good guy and hopefully it does work
well isn't that interesting that the
only person that come to speak to you so
far to teach you how to do well within
an industry is the only person that
isn't trying to sell a course within
that [ __ ] industry exactly as well so
to say the property guide you mentioned
I've had a few other property like
teachers or they've got podcasts and
they're like leaders in their books and
stuff like leaders in their sector
they've got in touch saying I can show
you the right way of doing these things
because some of the things that you see
in these events aren't a hundred percent
legal it's gray areas playing sort of
like both sides of the law this is the
way to do it any can make money through
property if you ever want to talk about
that or discuss that we're happy to help
you and that's what I think this
eventual leader it's not necessarily
which on naming individuals I think it
will show people here's what they
promise you here's the reality you know
you're probably going to be closer to
this than that so don't go and spend all
your money on this thing that doesn't
really
exist because we've shown you how much
when it cost us to make this amount of
money oh yeah well it's an open
challenge
ladies and gentlemen everybody that's
listening people of the internet if you
have a business and if you think that
you can help Mike make some of his half
a million quid back that he's lumped
into all manner of different different
things it carries on its rate I will
have to get I like to do a problem a
proper job because not one thing so far
has made money money and I tomorrow I've
got an interview with a guy that I
brought some crypto mining rigs off so I
spent thirty thousand pounds with him
and that would be an interesting
interview that's all I'm going to say
I'm excited man I'm very excited so for
the listeners who want to find out a
little bit more they can't watch the
Contra preneur formula yet but they
might be able to and if it is uploaded
by the time that this episode goes up it
will be in the show notes below but
where can they find you that hasn't been
taken down yet so I am on Instagram
which is just might win it I don't have
many followers and I don't follow anyone
I'm a proper weirdo and I'm on LinkedIn
Mike win it which is the same spell like
winner with a tee at the end rather than
an hour and then YouTube might win it
fantastic you need to go and have a
little bit of a look on LinkedIn this is
a total another episode and I'm you know
if you've got time manage some point
over the next couple of months I want to
do a whole delve deep into the world
weird world of LinkedIn because until
watching your stuff on YouTube I didn't
even know that there was this whole
subculture of like weird engagement [ __ ]
on LinkedIn it's like it's like
Instagram for people that have like
smoking jackets and so on Chesterfield
sofas it's amazing yeah I say what
LinkedIn is just Facebook for a
professional wankers that's the best way
to describe it there we go and on that
note we'll finish like share subscribe
you know what to do really appreciate
your time Mike thank you so much man and
good luck as everything comes forward
[Music]